Guten Morgen Linus. Guten Morgen Tim. Passt auf Kuh, ja? Ja. Und bist erholt jetzt?
Guten Morgen Tim. Ja. Ja, aber wie das so ist bei der Kur, ne? Woche länger hätte auch nicht geschadet, aber ich musste ja zurück, weil kaum bist du mal eine Woche weg, ne?
Dann will man noch ewig bleiben.
Nee, machen die ja nur Scheiße hier.
Ach so, na ja. Das müssen wir uns mal genauer anschauen.
Was denn, was denn? Was meinst du denn? Meinst du hier, unsere Freunde aus äh aus den Parlamenten?
Aus den Parlamenten, ja. Das äh äh ist doch spannend, hättest du damit gerechnet.
Tja, ach äh na ja, wie gesagt, ich äh habe
durchaus damit gerechnet, dass sie darüber abstimmen, ob ich die Wette laufen, dass sie damit irgendwie nicht hier nicht durchkommen. So, das schon vor dem Thema, oder was?
Ja, hätte ich jetzt gedacht, ich trinke noch einen Schluck Orangensaft, aber.
Ja, also Hauptsache du bist jetzt gut geschmiert.
Ich da äußere ich mich nicht zu.
Na ja, also auf jeden Fall äh unsere Freunde im Parlament scheinen ausreichend gut äh geschmiert zu sein.
Da gibt's immer schön Orangensaft. Und ähm,
das Leistungs äh Schutzrecht, das was hier seit Monaten eigentlich ein Thema ist und auch die äh Internetwolke nicht zur Ruhe hat kommen lassen,
Ist also nun beschlossen worden. Ähm wie wir hier schon in der letzten Woche angekündigt haben, gab's so eine Last-Minute-Änderung, wo dann äh
äh das Ganze so nochmal irgendwie diffusreduziert wurde auf äh einzelne Wörter oder kleinste Textausschnitte seien jetzt äh von dieser Leistungsschutzregelung irgendwie ausgenommen
was auch einfach diese gesamte sich abzeichnete Perspektive mit diesem Gesetz, dass das alles Wischiwaschi ist und letzten Endes nur von Juristen und äh äh Anwälten geklärt wird.
Gut, ne? Juristen und Anwälte.
Ja gut, da kann man durchaus nochmal eine.
Gerichten und Anwälten würde ich sagen. Ähm das einfach nochmal deutlich unterstreicht, weil's halt einfach eine totale Nebelkerze ist und man einfach überhaupt nicht mehr weiß, was jetzt gilt.
Ja, das Spannende ist ja, dass jetzt eigentlich beide unglücklich sind, ne? Also die eine Seite ist unglücklich, weil's ein Leistungsschutzrecht gibt, die andere Seite ist unglücklich, weil,
dieses Leistungsschutzrechtsgesetz irgendwie genau dieses Loopol hat, dass ähm einzelne Wörter oder kleinste Textausschnitte nicht definiert ist,
und sich jetzt genau die Frage stellt, äh was ist der kleinste Textausschnitt? Das erinnert mich ein bisschen so an die ähm geringe Menge,
die geringe Menge, die äh bei die man an an äh.
Drogen. Drogen haben darf, ja. Ja.
An Drogen haben darf, ja, die in jedem äh Bundesland dann je nach äh Belastung irgendwie unterschiedlich liegt. Ich glaube, in Berlin liegt das irgendwie so bei äh,
bei äh bei Hanfprodukten irgendwie bei bis zu zehn Gramm
in anderen Bundesländern dann irgendwie 'ne sehr viel geringere Zahl ist, bei der dann die Staatsanwaltschaft sagt, OK hier verfolgen wir nicht oder so. Könnte mir vorstellen, dass dass bei dem Leistungsschutzrichter kommt's jetzt auch darauf an
die Gerichte urteilen, was jetzt also ein kleinster Textausschnitt ist,
Wenn ich das richtig nachgelesen habe, äh bemühte sich die FDP ja, das irgendwie zu definieren mit irgendwie hundertsechzig Zeichen oder sowas, ja?
Ähm aber solange jetzt der kleinste Textausschnitt nicht definiert ist, äh ist das ein natürlich eine maximale äh rechtliche Unsicherheit.
Also wie gesagt, solange jetzt keine, solange es keine Grenze gibt, was der kleinste Textausschnitt ist.
Kann es sein, dass einfach alles so weitergeht wie bisher, also dass dass man sagt, okay, also das, was Google macht, ist ein kleinster Textausschnitt,
ähm.
Und äh es geht für alle äh glücklich weiter ähm oder eben nicht. Ähm Frank Westfal der Betreiber der des Aggregators River hat ja schon gesagt, also so er muss im Prinzip jetzt,
das irgendwie einzuprogrammieren bei,
ähm bei bei Presseerzeugnissen dann irgendwie deine andere Maßgabe anzulegen oder so, dass er jetzt im Prinzip auf die Textausschnitte komplett verzichten muss,
sich nicht in der Grauzone begeben will.
Und äh ist natürlich dann schon schade, also es war ja eh die ganze Zeit klar, dass es am Ende River treffen würde,
Das ist so, dass das Paradebeispiel ist für jemanden, der maximal darunter leidet oder vernünftigen Dienst, der maximal darunter leidet.
Ja, ich meine Blacklist, ne, also.
Ja, das das möchte er nicht, weil weil es ursprünglich war's ja so, dass das äh im Prinzip keine Presseerzeugnisse aufgenommen hat,
sondern eher so auf diesen, auf den Blogusphären Teil sich bezogen hat, aber wenn halt grade mal wieder so 'n so 'ne,
Text eben das heißt diskutierte Thema der Bloßphäre ist, dann will er es eben auch bei River äh widergespiegelt sehen, ne.
Ja, das kann ich natürlich verstehen, aber äh am Ende äh
kann er sich dann natürlich jetzt auch nicht beliebig da in Gefahr äh begeben und genau das ist ja dann eben das äh Problem. Ich meine, die ganze Sache, ich weiß nicht, rechtskräftig ist das jetzt, glaube ich, erstmal noch gar nicht, sondern das ist ja sozusagen erstmal nur mal beschlossen, dass es eingeführt werden soll,
Ähm hast du was von einem Datum.
Nee, nee, das ist ja deshalb noch erstmal, erstmal muss man ja noch einen anderen interessanten Aspekt benennen,
Also entschieden wurde es mit zweihundertdreiundneunzig zu zweihundertvierunddreißig Stimmen bei drei Enthaltungen,
Zweihundertdreiundvierzig, genau und ähm der von der Apple Opposition haben sich insgesamt zweiundfünfzig Abgeordnete ähm bei der Abstimmung nicht gezeigt. Die waren einfach nicht da,
und hätten diese zweiundfünfzig fehlenden Oppositionsabgeordneten mit nein gestimmt,
dann wären das, ne, summa summarum, zweihundertfünfundneunzig nein gegen zweihundertdreiundneunzig Ja-Stimmen gewesen und das Leistungsschutzrecht wäre am,
Ersten Mär.
Wir wissen natürlich auch, dass das so nicht die Gepflogenheiten sind im Parlament.
Interessant, interessanterweise. Da gab's ja dann ähm,
Also, da gab's einen interessanten Artikel von Wolfgang Michael bei Kater Punkt Info. Erstmal war's ja dann wurde halt äh vermutet, dass es eine Vereinbarung ist, ja? Dass das.
Bei uns können so und so viele Leute nicht kommen. Zur Abstimmung.
Genau, schickt die mal bei euch auch nicht hin. Ja, damit damit die quasi ein
der die Toskana Reise eines Abgeordneten nicht jetzt das Abstimmungsergebnis gefährdet? Kann man sich dann darauf verlassen, dass einer von der Opposition an dem Tag dann auch äh.
Bei der CDU fällt keiner in die Toskana.
Ist viel zu schnös, viel zu.
Dass er ja alles voll mit Sozen.
Stimmt. Ja, okay, also äh das, dass man also sagt, okay, wir wir äh die Mehrheitsverhältnisse sind hier irgendwie heilig und wir wollen ja alle mal irgendwie freimachen oder können ja auch alle mal nicht insofern waren wir diese diese Mehrheitsverhältnisse.
Und ähm das war ja auch etwas, was bei der äh Konstanz hatte, dass ja erzählt, dass das in der Internet-Oncate quasi automatisch.
Als dann eben mal grade einer nicht da war, dass die dann da die Abstimmungen verschoben haben, als ihnen einleuchtete Mist, wenn man das heute abstimmen, dann äh,
geht's nicht, ne?
Also ähm da wurde der wurde dann vermutet, dass und dann sagte einer irgendwie ähm wer twitterte das, Wolfgang, äh nee Volker
Sagte dann, ja, es gab eine Paringvereinbarung. Petra Sitte sagte, es gab keine. Na ja, hin und her. So und jetzt hatte der Wolfgang Michael eben mal geschaut, wer hat sich denn jetzt nicht an der Abstimmung beteiligt?
Und sagte dann so von der SPD, Sigmar Gabriel, Andrea Nahles, äh Wolfgang Thierse, so, also alles irgendwie spitzenleute, ja? Und bei der, bei den Grünen ebenso, irgendwie Jürgen Trittin, Claudia Roth,
Katrin Göring-Eckardt und solche Leute, ne? Und blinken Sahra Wagenknecht, also im Prinzip die Spitzen waren nicht da und er sagt,
ähm jetzt bin ich erstmal sehr gespannt. Ähm also er, er sagt, die Opposition wollte sich den kommenden, großen Auftritt im Bundesrat nicht nehmen lassen und das ungeliebte Gesetz jetzt schon vom Herd nehmen,
die schwarz-gelbe Koalition soll noch ein bisschen in der Netzhölle schmoren müssen. Das äh vermutet er.
Sowas hat das damit zu tun, ob die dann davor also ob die nun der Abstimmung fern bleiben oder nicht.
Dass sie, dass sie quasi sagen, lasst den Bundestag das mal beschließen, lass mal alle sich aufregen und wir kassieren's dann nachher im Bundesrat.
Denn das Gesetz ist zwar nicht ähm nicht äh zustimmungspflichtig. Im Bundesratsmäßig, aber weil die SPD regierten Länder die Mehrheit in im Bundesrat haben, können sie einen Einspruch erheben,
Und ähm dann könnten sie das, also die SPD hat jetzt die Möglichkeit, wenn sie, ne, vereint, in vereinten Reihen steht, äh das Leistungsschutzrecht in den Vermittlungsausschuss zu bringen.
Und dafür ähm müssten sie sich also einfach alle, also es könnte die SPD jetzt machen.
Ja gut, aber ein Vermittlungsausschuss bringt ja nicht nicht unbedingt das Gesetz als solches zu Fall, sondern es muss sozusagen Details neu ausgehandelt werden, die auch schon vorher äh besprochen wurden und dann äh geht es sozusagen über die das einzige, was jetzt hier greifen könnte, wäre, dass man eben
einfach äh wie nennen die Amerikaner das so schön? Ähm,
Äh Philipp, ja, dass dass sie das sozusagen jetzt so lange in die Länge ziehen und totquatschen, äh bis die Koalition halt da an ihre
Sommerpause und damit dann eben auch an ihre Legislatur Legislativ,
Grenze kommt. Also, ne? September wird gewählt und ähm,
dem Moment, wo der Bundestag in seiner Sommerpause geht, ist es eigentlich dann auch im wesentlichen vorbei. Also danach wird dann nicht mehr groß beschlossen. Die kommen dann aus dem Urlaub zurück, dann wird noch ein bisschen Weih gekämpft und äh.
Angeguckt und dann geht's los.
Ich fand die These jetzt mal ganz interessant. Also es.
Ist auf jeden Fall eine interessante These. Ähm warum das jetzt bedeuten muss, dass die da nicht anwesend sind, weiß ich nicht, weil ich meine, die hätten auch genauso gut anwesend sein können und dagegen stimmen.
Das hat die Frage, also.
Wäre das Ergebnis auch knapper gewesen. Äh und dann können sie immer noch einen Bundesrat dagegen sein und dann klingt's auch ein bisschen glaubwürdiger,
Ja, also ich weiß ich nicht, aber vielleicht verstehe ich da auch einfach die die Politlogik nicht ausreichend.
So oder so, ähm was wir hier letzte Woche nur angerissen haben, es gab ja auch kurz vorher nochmal so eine Studie vom äh Eco äh EV in Zusammenarbeit mit dem.
Ach Gottchen. Also eine Studie zum Leistungsschutzrecht,
Die die Verfassungsmäßigkeit dieser Gesetzesinitiative äh mal wieder ein weiteres Mal in Frage stellt. Und,
Thema ist auch noch nicht vom Tisch. Also.
Grundsätzlich ist einfach diese ganze Regelung nach wie vor umstritten, auf allen nur erdenklichen Ebenen und eigentlich gibt's niemanden, der da auch wirklich irgendein nennenswertes Argument bringt.
So ist das.
Stefan Negemeier hat ja dann gleich einen Tag nach der äh Beschließung auch gleich noch so ein äh Post abgesetzt. Ich weiß nicht, ob du den äh gesehen hast.
Ähm.
Die Presse dann sozusagen auch gleich ins Horn gestoßen hat.
Ja, ja, die einen, äh genau, das das machen jetzt alle, ne? Also die einen.
Also die fanden dann sozusagen, mussten dann hier der Bundesverband Deutscher Zeitungsverleger äh hat sich dann auch gleich äh entsprechend geäußert und meinte so, ja ähm,
Ist ja jetzt äh deutlich klar und jetzt können wir ja hier irgendwie gegen Google mal ordentlich vorgehen. Ne, also jetzt kommen die sozusagen auch alle ein bisschen so aus ihren äh Löchern und der äh Reserve.
Es bleibt spannend. Mein Tipp steht.
Dein Stipp bleibt dann heißt das dann.
Findet nicht statt.
Finde nicht statt. Da musste natürlich der These von, also dann gibt's für dich irgendwie die beiden Optionen Bundesverfassungsgericht oder oder wer weiß also irgendwie oberstes Gericht.
Ich denke halt Verfassungsgericht.
Oder Bundesrat.
Ja, wie gesagt, also beim Bundesrat, ich,
dem Bundesrat kann da verzögern und der kann da Änderungen und Entschärfungen reinbringen. Aber ich glaube, der ganze Kernpunkt und diese Entschärfung hat ja im Prinzip schon stattgefunden. Also diese Einschränkung, die da drin ist
wie auch immer man die jetzt deuten mag. Ist ja im Prinzip auch schon immer eine Verweichlichung. Das zeigt auch meiner Meinung nach,
dass es hier eigentlich auch sehr viel mehr erstmal darum geht, dass überhaupt was beschlossen wird. Das ist überhaupt erstmal diese Kategorie Leistungsschutzrecht gibt, weil verschärfen und ändern,
kann man immer noch. So und das ist halt auch der der normale Weg der Dinge. Wenn's erstmal so ein Vehikel gibt, dann kann man dann irgendwann mal, wenn äh die Schwarzen wieder in der Regierung sind, kann man dann vielleicht mal die kleinsten Textausschnitte da äh rausnehmen aus dem Ausschluss,
ja? Und die einzelnen Wörter dann auch irgendwann und dann dann hast du halt auch irgendwann mal wieder das, was du äh eigentlich haben wolltest.
Ich kann mir auch ehrlich gesagt auch irgendwie nicht vorstellen, dass die dass die Sozialdemokraten irgendwie wirklich so ein, so ein geistiges Eigentumsrecht irgendwie,
für die Arme sterbende Presse, dass die sich hinstellen, das kassieren. Also,
bin ganz ehrlich äh ich glaube, dass die oder schon die Debatte ums Leistungsschutzrecht jetzt im normalen Gefilden der Gesellschaft hat schon gezeigt, dass ähm.
Also das ist doch schon durchaus eher so ist, dass der dass Leute auch sich für das Argument erwerben können, dass die Presse da im Internet kaputt geht und dass man da, dass man da was gegen tun muss, ja.
Und ich kann mir ich wüsste nicht, ob es für die für die SPD strategisch klug wäre,
tatsächlich in also so dass das wirklich zu Fall zu bringen. Mal sehen. Ähm wir werden wir werden es äh.
Dauert auf jeden Fall alles noch ein Jahr, bis wir da wirklich Klarheit haben und bis dahin ist die Internetdisruption auch schon wieder ein paar Schritte weitergekommen.
Ja, also ich meine, die Zeit läuft so, ne, das ist vollkommen klar. Und jedes weitere Jahr, wie sich Deutschland äh um solche Phantomdebatten eigentlich kümmert, anstatt mal die wirklich wichtigen Sachen anzugehen und hier Infrastrukturausbau äh zu fördern.
Von mir kam gerade aus Hongkong zurück und erzählte mir so, dass ich jedem Hochhaus gibt's halt irgendwie den hundert Megabit Anschluss irgendwie für vierzig Euro. So, wie direkt so.
Wo sind wir?
Äh das sind so wirklich die wichtigen äh Probleme und davon wird halt einfach gar nichts angegangen. Es wird halt auch deshalb eben nicht angegangen, weil einfach ein kulturelles Problem existiert. Weil einfach,
Man sich die ganze Zeit nur mit dem oh Gott, was kann das Internet alles kaputt machen, beschäftigt,
anstatt eben wirklich da auch mal äh auf eine Chance äh zu setzen und aktiv zu fördern und eben nicht gerade mit solchen
Sachen im Prinzip das Rad permanent immer wieder zurückdrehen zu wollen. Was letztlich nicht gelingt, sondern eben einfach nur anderen zugute kommt. Das ist einfach traurig.
Nun gut, haben wir da noch was zu zu äh sagen?
Nö, wir gucken mal, ne? Also.
Ja, dann gab's Nachrichten in den USA.
Ja
Bradley Menning hat äh ein Teilgeständnis. Im Fall WikiLeaks Ausplauderrei äh zum besten gegeben? Ja.
Bei einer Voruntersuchung, also seine äh Verfahrenseröffnung wird so für für August,
prophezeit und es gab eine Voruntersuchung vor allem Militärgericht in Fort Meet und mit DE und ähm,
hat äh er dann sich von in zehn, von zweiundzwanzig Anklagepunkten für schuldig erklärt, hat er irgendwie über dreißig Seiten äh verlesen,
und die in den zentralen Punkt ein Staatsfeind zu sein. Ich denke, dass äh dann also das ist dieses Ading wie Anney,
den hätte natürlich zurückgewiesen, weil darauf steht die Todesstrafe.
Interessanter Punkt seiner Aussage ist, also er hat, er hat natürlich, sage ich mal, so grob die Motive angegeben, die man ähm,
erwartet, beziehungsweise die ja auch schon äh in größeren Teilen Adrian Lemmo in den dann geliebten Chatlocks äh mitgeteilt hat
ja? Dass ihr also denkt, dass das äh dass das da Skandale sind, die er da aufdeckt und äh dass er von diesen Reuters äh von der Reuterspresse
gehört hatte, die also die das Video von der Ermordung ihrer äh Journalisten durch diesen Helikopterangriff äh nicht bekommen konnte und dass er dass er da ja, also an,
sein Gewissen ähm äh ja.
Dass das irgendwie sein Gewissen gegangen ist und dass er dann da äh eben diese Handlung verführt hat. Spannender Punkt ist, dass er sagt, er hätte das vorher der Washington Post und den New der New York Times angeboten.
Die hätten die Materialien nicht haben wollen. Ähm.
Oho.
So und dann betont er, dass er oder das da kommt der der wichtige Punkt, dass er zu keinem Zeitpunkt von Wiki Leaks bedrängt wurde das Material der Organisation zu überlassen. Ne, er sagt so, also Wiki League so,
Ähm dass er quasi in einem Chat von einem der von dem er vermutet, dass das Julian Assange war, ähm,
sich halt erklären lassen, wie er dieses Material denen jetzt zukommen lässt am besten, was ja auch viele Sachen sind, viel äh größerer Datensatz. Und ähm,
Dass diese Person ihn aber nicht gedrängt hätte,
auch nicht ermutigt hätte oder so. Das ist ein relativ wichtiger Punkt, weil das wäre der äh der potenzielle äh,
Anstiftung zum Landesverrat, die Julian Assange endlich auf eine klare Liste setzen könnte. Ähm,
äh holt er ihn also sehr klar äh zieht er den da aus der Schusslinie und.
Und sich selber eigentlich in die Schusslinie.
Und sie ist sehr, ja, aber ich habe da ähm schon die Tage mich drüber unterhalten. Der junge Mann ist verloren. So, das ist der ist jetzt,
Der ist jetzt Märtyrer. Da müssen wir uns mit dem Gedanken müssen wir uns anfreunden. Es geht im Prinzip bei diesem Verfahren nur noch darum, ob der sterben wird oder ob der in Gefangenenschaft sterben wird.
Also die ähm selbst für die zehn Anklagepunkte, für die er sich jetzt äh schuldig bekannt hat, stehen halt irgendwie zwanzig Jahre.
Jeweils oder.
Insgesamt, ne? Für die, also insgesamt zwanzig Jahre könnten wir jetzt so das höchste Strafmaß, was ihn ähm was ihn erwartet. Und jetzt ähm also wir reden da ja von, dass er auch kein Zivilist, sondern es ist ein ein Soldat,
und was der gemacht hat,
Unabhängig davon, was also jetzt nur aus aus der Strukturarmee betrachtet. Ja, der hat eine ähm ein Vertrauen, was irgendwie diese Armee äh in ihn gesetzt hat,
massiv missbraucht. Ja? Und hat hat da in geheimen klassifizierte Informationen rausgetragen und irgendwie veröffentlicht.
Unabhängig davon, dass ich ihn persönlich für einen äh absoluten Helden halte für das, was er getan hat, kann ein äh eine Militärstruktur, so was ja in keiner Form tolerieren,
die müssen denen einfach maximal platt machen, wenn sie,
sicher gehen wollen, dass sie in Zukunft ihren kompletten Militär für Elefants da überhaupt noch aufrecht erhalten können,
Wenn die den jetzt nicht, weiß ich nicht, für eine völlig utopische Anzahl von Jahren wegschließen oder töten,
können sie ihren Laden dicht machen,
Weil sie damit, also das ist jetzt das Exempel, so für die nächsten für die vergangenen und die zukünftigen Jahrzehnte. Und das wird an ihm statuiert werden. Da,
der kommt da nicht mehr raus. Bin ich mir sehr, sehr sicher.
Und ähm das ist natürlich äh sehr, sehr bedauerlich, sehr sehr fürchterlich,
Für diesen Menschen, aber von der also als Struktur, Militär ist ganz klar nachvollziehbar, was was die machen werden, machen müssen.
Ähm interessantes Sidenote an der Stelle ist äh
dass der Sabo, wir hatten den jungen Mann behandelt, das ist der der dessen das FBI habhaft geworden war ähm,
Hauptverhandlung verschiebt sich jetzt irgendwie noch, weil der grade so gut mit dem FBI kollaboriert?
Erstmal.
Ja, der muss noch weitere sechs Monate, ähm dem wollen sie noch ein bisschen. Also sie sie ich glaube, dass sie so ungefähr sagen, der hilft uns gerade so gut,
Das könnte sich noch ähm,
sehr positiv auf eine Verminderung des Strafmaßes auswirken und ähm deswegen lassen wir den jetzt noch ein bisschen weiter hier ähm uns helfen.
Ähm ja, das steht also das ähm,
dass also es ist ein Brief, das die US-Department of Justice an den Richter und sagen, sie würden gerne,
dass die dass das Ganze die ganze Angelegenheit hier vom Februar in den August verschieben in Light of the Defendems on going Cooperation with the goverment.
Und sagen also, ja, weil er uns gerade so gut hilft, ähm,
würden wir das gerne noch ein bisschen verschieben. Äh bis wir ihn verurteilen lassen. Um das gesamte Ausmaß seiner Hilfe dann auch mit in Strafmaß einfließen zu lassen. Und da wird's jetzt spannend, weil,
Der ja wiederum auch ähm eventuell die Möglichkeit hat, den äh,
Julio Sanchez da ans ähm ans Messer zu liefern, wenn er nämlich aussagt oder beweist, dass der Julian Assange sie irgendwie motiviert hätte, bestimmte Dinge zu hacken für Wiki Leaks,
also voraus also wenn das jetzt so geschehen wäre und er das so aussagen würde. Das wäre also jetzt das wäre also ein weiterer Vektor, äh der auf Julian Assange stünde. Das heißt, Julian Assange,
wird diesen Brief den das Department of Justice an den Richter im Fall Sabo geschickt hat mit relativ,
Nervosität gelesen haben. Als er bei AS Techniker veröffentlicht wurde.
Hm. Außerdem ist er noch für den Nobelpreis vorgeschlagen worden.
Bradley Menning.
Also nicht.
Nominiert, sondern äh ja genau, also Bradley Menning äh von äh,
Das ist jetzt hier ein Artikel von äh Brigitte, die ja auch zu dem Team gehörte, was seiner Zeit dieses Collateral Murdervideo mit unterstützt hat, also dessen Veröffentlichung.
Eine isländische Parlamentsabgeordnete.
Sehr bekannt für ihren äh Aktivismus und ähm,
Interessante Personen und jetzt irgendwie dem, also sie und andere haben äh dem Nobelpreiskomitee da einen Brief geschrieben und vorgeschrieben, dass doch bitte Bradley Menning für Nobelpreis für den Friedensnobelpreis vorgesehen,
Äh werden sollte. Ob das erwogen wird, dort das steht in den Sternen.
Ich denke mir, dass das äh Nobelpreiskomitee äh da schon den Anruf bekommen haben wird.
So, Jungs, sag mal, ähm diesen Brief da nimmt der doch nicht ernst, ne? Nehmen wir ihn. Ach Quatsch. Also ich denke schon, dass mit denen, dass.
Ja, aber ich meine, Obama hat den Nobelfriedensnobelpreis auch bekommen, ohne ihn wirklich verdient zu haben. Ich meine.
Bradley Menning könnte man behaupten, hätte den verdient, ja.
Ja eben, weil ich meine gleich ziehe ich das doch wieder aus.
Also ich fänd's super.
Also ich meine, wenn Obama ihn deswegen zurückgibt, ist es jetzt nicht so schlimm, weil er irgendwie sehe ich jetzt nicht so sehr da jetzt verdient gemacht hat.
Nee, ich fänd's vor allem geil, wenn die USA einen Friedensnobelpreisträger hinrichten. Also ich fänd's nicht geil. Also ich meine, aber sie also quasi dieser, ich meine,
Sollte er innerhalb der nächsten Jahre den Friedensnobelpreis bekommen, wird er auf jeden Fall sollten sie ihn zum Tode verurteilen, dauert das noch ein paar Jahre, bis ihn tatsächlich dann töten. Wenn sie, wenn er bis dahin noch einen Friedensnobelpreis kriegt,
haben die USA jemanden zum Tode verurteilt, der einen Friedensnobelpreis hat? Und das und müssen den dann töten?
Ja, vor allem durchgeführt und beschlossen und unterschrieben von einem Friedensnobelpreisträger.
Ja. Es kann nur einen geben.
Die prägen sich jetzt alle gegenseitig um. Oh Gott.
Okay, also jetzt mal nicht,
Nicht darüber lachen, aber ich denke, dass äh dass das der ähm der Hintergrund dieser Aktion auch ist, ja? Also natürlich wäre das also das wäre so einer der wenigen Punkte, wie man wie man da einen,
Wie man das doch echt drehen könnte. Entsprechend denke ich auch, wird da der ähm.
Wird da der ähm diplomatische Druck äh schon auch sein im Rahmen dieser ähm und welchen Einfluss die USA auf die äh Definition des Friedensnobelpreisträgers haben, zeigt ja gerade, äh dass Obama diesen Titel da bekommen hat. Also
aussichtslos, aber ich äh ich denke, das wäre echt noch so eine Lebensrettungsmaßnahme für Bradley Menning, wenn man ihm jetzt echt einen Friedensnobelpreis äh.
Wir werden's sehen. Bevor wir jetzt hier uns hier ins äh hineinstürzen,
blättern wir lieber ein bisschen vor, gehen wir nach Deutschland äh da sind ja auch noch ein paar andere Lieblingsthemen am Start. Zum Beispiel unsere Freunde von.
Hat äh also musst dir vorstellen, die GEMA, die da sitzen so Leute, da ist einer, die haben so einen Computer und da googeln die dann so, googeln Musik,
und um gucken, was da so kommt und überlegen, ob da irgendwas bei ist.
Woran die noch nicht Geld verdienen, ja?
Woran sie noch nicht Geld verdienen, ja? Wenn dann das, wenn dann da steht, ich habe Musik auf meinen MP3, auf meinen USB-Stick gemacht, dann sagen die, USB-Stickabgabe.
Und wenn da steht irgendwie, ich habe Musik in einer Diskothek gehört, dann sagen die,
Preiserhöhung für Clubs. Das haben wir im letzten Jahr schon besprochen. Hm? Und jetzt haben sie der letzte Stand war ja, dass sie ähm,
im Dezember irgendwie 'ne Anhörung bei der Schiedsstelle des deutschen Patent- und Markenamt Markenamtes hatten und die große GEMA-Reform, bei der ja dann die Clubs so stark zur Kasse gebeten werden sollten,
erstmal auf zweitausendvierzehn verschoben sollte, verschoben wurde,
Um man damit rechnete, dass im April zweitausenddreizehn so ein endgültiger Schietspruch,
dann stattfindet. Der also dann sagt OK diese GEMA-Tarifreform ist OK oder nicht? Und,
Das war also die Verschiebung, aber erstmal haben sie gesagt, wir wir lassen die Tarife ab dem ersten Januar zweitausenddreizehn um fünf Prozent erhöhen, für alle Musikveranstalter.
Ähm und am ersten April zweitausenddreizehn erhöhen sie sich dann für Diskotheken, um Clubs nochmal um
zehn Prozent. Das ist jetzt der aktuelle Stand. Das heißt, sie haben den Status quo gelassen und äh klar, so einfach prozentual Erhöhungen gemacht, ja?
Ah, der ein entscheidender Faktor war der sogenannte Laptop-Zuschlag, von dem sie jetzt Abstand genommen haben oder der der fällt also jetzt weg. Und der äh.
Fand also statt, wenn Musik mit Computern oder selbstgebrannten CDs gespielt wurde, dann ähm mussten irgendwie dreißig Prozent mehr zahlen.
Also wer seinen DJs erlaubt, kopierte CDs oder Musikdateien von einem Notebook abzuspielen, zahlt dreißig Prozent mehr an die GEMA. Aber mit welcher Begründung auch immer.
Also generell, wenn es überhaupt auch nur einem einzigen erlaubt wird, aber das machen doch alle DJs.
Ja, aber jetzt müssen wir mehr zahlen. Also das war ähm ich weiß das, ich kann da jetzt Club
äh ein wenig sagen, aber ähm sehr guter Freund von mir betreibt eine Kneipe und da war das äh war das durchaus ein Faktor, dass also die GEMA sagt, was weiß ich, Betrag X
wenn du nur Original-CDs spielst, Betrag X plus,
Dreißig Prozent oder oder also ein ein höherer Betrag, wenn äh die Leute auch ähm,
MP3-Player oder so was anschließen. Kostet dann einfach mehr. Grundsätzlich, Punkt. Keine keine Ahnung wieso, ja? Ähm.
Aber das den gab's also auch tatsächlich. Und ähm.
Der war auch in den letzten Jahren, also war das so. Ähm.
Und jetzt das fällt also weg. Das heißt, der äh unabhängig davon, was die Leute spielen, ähm haben die Veranstalter jetzt keinen Aufpreis dafür, ja? Sie haben einfach die grundsätzliche Erhöhung um zehn Prozent ähm ab.
Nehmen sie den dreißig Prozent Aufschlag weg und bejubeln das mit wie viel fairer und toller das doch ist.
So und jetzt, jetzt kommt der spannende Punkt. Ähm das heißt, der der Veranstalter war grundsätzlich verantwortlich für die, für das Abfüllen der GEMA-Gebühren. Ähm,
und in der Regel haben sie ja dann so pauschal irgendwas bezahlt statt irgendwie da die ganzen einzelnen Lieder nachzuspulen und so, kennen wir ja alles. Ähm,
Und jetzt muss ein DJ,
Für jede einzelne Datei, die zur Aufführung vorgesehen ist, der DJ, eine Lizenzabgabe von drei Cent entrichten,
Und das ist das, was der DJ machen muss. Und da gibt's also ein schönes Rechenbeispiel, wenn da jetzt so
sagen wir mal hundert Gighut, ich sage mal, grob fünfzehntausend Dateien, dann wären das bei dreizehn Cent pro Datei jährlich eintausendneunhundertfünfzig Euro, die der DJ an die GEMA zu bezahlen hat, dafür, dass er
legal erworbene Musik auf Festplatten vorhält.
Zum Einsatz bringt.
Ja, das ist ja nur das Spannende. Für jede einzelne Teil, die zur Aufführung vorgesehen ist, das wäre das jetzt auch nochmal die Frage. Also ähm.
Ach so, noch nicht mal, wenn sie tatsächlich abgespielt ist oder nur das Kopieren sozusagen.
So lese ich das. Da gibt's also ein relativ krudes Interview, in dem Musikmagazin Diback.
Ja. Ähm.
In dem jemand von der äh GEMA da im im Interview so allen möglichen Kram da von sich gibt. Also es ist wieder so jemand von der GEMA, der äh,
Also bei aller bei aller Kritik an dem, was er sowieso sagt, irgendwie auch nicht so ganz weiß, was was sie da ernsthaft machen. Also er wird gefragt, ähm.
Wenn ich jetzt eine wenn also wenn ich jetzt quasi einen Datenträger habe, also ich habe ich habe die zum Beispiel von mir aus zu Hause auf einer auf einer Festplatte und.
Ähm kopiere sie jetzt ähm nochmal auf eine andere Festplatte.
Da muss man nochmal bezahlen,
Also wenn sagt er wörtlich, es ist grundsätzlich zu zahlen. Das heißt, wenn von einem Werk mehrere Kopien, die zur öffentlichen Wiedergabe bestimmt sind, angefertigt werden, ist für all diese Kopien eine Vergütung zu zahlen,
für Kopien, die vor dem ersten vierten zweitausenddreizehn erstellt wurden, müssen die Vervielfältigungsrechte auch erworben werden. Das heißt,
Der Zeitpunkt der Tarifveröffentlichung hat keinen äh Einfluss auf den Sachverhalt der Vervielfältigung. Ähm.
Unverständlich alles.
Und dann sagt ihr selber noch, nur damit wir uns jetzt hier nicht missverstehen, für die öffentliche Wiedergabe der vervielfältigten Rechte ist selbstverständlich eine zusätzliche Vergütung vom Diskothekeninhaber zu bezahlen. Wer also der Diskothek.
Also ich fasse es nochmal mit meinen Worten zusammen,
Der DJ kauft Musik und zahlt in dem Moment den Kaufpreis und entrichtet damit ja einen Künstler und einen Verlager und wer sonst noch da irgendwas hat, irgendwie Geld.
Dann hatte es irgendwie auf irgendeinem Datenträger, der aber schon auch seine eigene Festplatte sein kann, weil es ja auch so ist, dass man die Musik vielleicht auch,
Digital gekauft hat.
Da hat er dann auch schon mal eine Gebühr für bezahlt, weil er hat jetzt einen USB-Stick, da hat er ja auch schon mal.
Also ich kaufe die jetzt einfach so auf meinem Computer, was weiß ich, geh zu iTunes, kaufe das irgendwie, damit habe ich ja was bezahlt. So, jetzt liegt das auf meiner Platte. Jetzt kopiere ich das auf eine externe Festplatte oder einen USB-Stick,
Dann muss ich nochmal,
Dafür bezahlen, dass ich das tun darf. Sozusagen zwischen meinen eigenen Datenträgern hin und her, sofern diese externe Festplatte dafür ein vorgesehen ist, äh in der Aufführung bereitzustehen,
Aber nicht das, was ich tatsächlich aufführe, muss ich bezahlen, sondern nur die Bereitstellung sozusagen auf meinem eigenen Medien, wo ich Festplatten für gekauft habe.
Für dich auch schon vorher äh,
noch ein Teil, also wohl im Kaufpreis ja schon vorgesehen ist, dass genau dieses Kopieren stattfindet und deswegen auch eine Abgabe ist. Genauso übrigens auch auf meinem iPhone und auf meinem iPod und so weiter äh auch schon eine solche Gebühr drauf ist,
So, dann spiele ich dir als DJ ab, in dem Laden und weil ich das tue, muss dann der Diskothekenbesitzer dafür auch nochmal zahlen.
Ja
Während dem ganzen Leute zuhören, die am Eintritt auch Geld zahlen müssen an die GEMA, der Teil vom Eintritt ist.
Das im Moment nicht, das wäre erst ab zweitausendvierzehn dann der Fall, weil.
Gut, aber das haben sie sozusagen vor.
Wollen sie auch noch, ja, ja klar. Ja. Mhm.
Also ich meine, ich frage mich ernsthaft, wie oft soll man eigentlich bezahlen, um irgendwie ein Musikstück zu hören? Also es ist einfach irgendwann besteht das alles nur noch aus GEMA,
So und keiner hat irgendwas verdient, kein DJ, kein, kein Barbesitzer, nichts. Es ist.
Also insgesamt.
Also es zeigt einfach auch sehr schön, es ist vor allem mittlerweile auch so verworren, dass selbst GEMA-Vertreter selber nicht mehr in der Lage sind, eigentlich genau zu erklären, was eigentlich die Regeln sind.
Ich muss eine Sache noch sagen, also die sagt, die Lizenzen sind Einmalzahlungen für jedes aufgeführte Stück. Ähm.
Das heißt, wenn also dieses fünfzehntausend Stückbeispiel, das aber jetzt, das hat jetzt die Debut, nicht dieser Herr Rheindelmeier, ähm,
dann wäre das also und ich meine, ist natürlich auch klar, also sagen wir mal, der DJ kommt jetzt mit seiner tausend äh Stückplatte an, ja? Ähm und,
spielt jetzt davon hundert pro Abend,
ja? Und spielt vielleicht, weil er bei häufigen Gigs irgendwie Stücke nochmal spielt, vielleicht insgesamt in einem Jahr fünfhundert verschiedene Lieder,
ähm dann würde er natürlich nur für diese fünfhundert bezahlen, jeweils dreizehn Cent und nicht für die fünfzehntausend, die ihr sonst noch,
auf der Festplatte eventuell vorhält.
Der Rheindelmeier scheint aber jetzt hier so zu das zu interpretieren, dass man äh trotzdem wegen der Vervielfältigung schon allein dafür, dass er sie mitnimmt, bezahlen muss, aber die Divak äh,
versteht ihn da anders. Also der ist ja noch der der äh der Obergag, ja. Also dieser ist sie.
Ähm
Wenn äh dann fragt die Divak, wenn Sicherungskopien, die nicht für die öffentliche Aufführung gemacht werden, nicht lizensierungspflichtig sind, kann ich dann nicht davon ausgehen, dass bei einem legal erworbenen Stück als Datei.
Nie eine Lizenz fällig ist, sofern ich immer nur eine Datei öffentlich aufhöre,
äh und da sagt er, okay dann, sie können davon ausgehen, dass da nicht nochmal eine Vergütung abfällt. Also okay, nur die vorgespielten.
Linus, jeder, der uns jetzt zugehört hat.
Nicht mehr verstanden habe.
Äh schon vor zwei Minuten komplett abgeschaltet. Das liegt aber weniger an dir. Ja, sondern es ist, es liegt einfach an dieser, an diesen Realitäten, die irgendwie einfach keiner mehr versteht. Ich meine, Wasser ist einfach sehr schön zeigt ähm,
ist es einfach niemand, äh was denn?
Es gibt am Ende des Artikels ein Schaubild. Da ist das dann einfach.
Oh ja, das ist ganz großartig.
Das äh klauen wir mal.
Das ist wirklich schön, wo man dann sehen kann, äh äh wann, also äh Flussdiagramm kann man das noch gar nicht mehr nennen, das ist mehr so ein Wollknoll von äh Verflechtung, von äh Bedingungen und äh Handlungsanweisungen.
Es ist großartig.
Ja, also.
Was man hier leider sehr schön sehen kann, ist, dass einfach diese ganze Lizenzierungsnummer einfach komplett gegen die Wand fährt. Ich meine,
Ja, also selbst, wenn man euch.
Selbst wenn man euch total toll findet und wichtig findet und, und, und, und, und in der Lage ist, äh euer Tun und Dasein irgendwie in den über den Klee zu loben.
Schwer fällt, selbst dann, es versteht einfach keiner mehr. Und es versteht vor allem also auch diese Herleitung, also ich verstehe auch überhaupt nicht, was die,
Legitimation dessen sein soll. Also ich meine, was bitte ist das Problem? Ich kaufe Musik und ich speichere sie dann auf einer Festplatte. Ich meine, wir sind uns ja einig,
es handelt sich dabei um das Selbe. Ja, es handelt sich zwar dabei um eine andere, digitale, ich will doch gar nicht von physikalisch äh Kopie sprechen,
Ja, also eine andere Repräsentierung des, des selben Dings und das ist ein reiner Convenience äh Faktor. Das ist so wie man einen Hammer mal in der Rechten und mal in der linken Hand hält,
Aber ich kaufe ja eigentlich auch den Hammer und zahle dann irgendwie nochmal Gebühren dafür, dass ich den auch in der linken Hand tragen darf,
Beziehungsweise auch noch auf den Werkzeuggürtel, damit ich mir irgendwie auch noch dahin stecken kann und so weiter. Ich meine, das ist einfach vollkommen albern,
Also ich ich verstehe einfach auch überhaupt nicht die äh beim besten Willen nicht, was jetzt hier die Legitimation dieser Logik sein soll. Also ich meine, was bitte verliert ein rechte äh,
Besitzer, ein Komponist, ein Musiker,
Was verliert er dadurch, dass der DJ, der diese Musik spielt? Ja, und dann eben auch im Idealfall natürlich legal erworben hat. Sie sich auf einen USB-Stick kopiert, um sie von da dann äh abzuspielen.
Oder? Also ich meine, das macht doch alles überhaupt gar keinen Sinn.
Es macht keinen Sinn.
Okay, dann sind wir uns da einig.
Das macht's ja auch so schwierig, das hier irgendwie zu vermitteln, ja wie.
Das kann man alles nicht mehr erklären.
Geh mal.
Einfach nicht vermittelbar.
Ich vermisse immer, ja.
Ja, wenn ihr mal vom Arbeitsamt steht, seid einfach nicht mehr vermittel.
Wartet's mal ab. Gut, ähm lass uns fortfahren.
Ja ähm ich glaube wir ähm wir können wir bleiben so ein bisschen beim beim Urheberrecht.
Weil's so schön war.
Ähm und zwar ist das jetzt eine Meldung, die ich so ein bisschen ähm also mich so ein bisschen wundert,
Äh wir erinnern uns an Acta,
Äh was ja in in Europa jetzt als als Tod äh dann gefeiert wurde und aber immerhin schon von Japan äh vollständig ratifiziert ist,
Ähm und ursprünglich waren ja insgesamt elf Länder beteiligt. Und jetzt kommt Kanada. Ähm.
Und ähm also die kanadische Regierung macht jetzt einen zweiundfünfzigseitigen Gesetzesvorschlag zu äh Urheberrecht, Markenrecht und Piraterie, der,
Im Prinzip vollständig,
Acta Compliant ist, also der der alles drin hat, was Acta ist. Die machen jetzt einfach innerhalb des Landes, ohne diesen ähm.
Ohne diesen ganzen Overhead eines internationalen schreiben die es einfach so in ihren äh nationalen Gesetzestext rein und in der äh zweitausenddreizehn Trade Policy Agenda,
ist dann auch ist dann auch dokumentiert, dass die USA und Kanada mit den anderen Ländern daran arbeiten. Akt hat trotzdem noch irgendwie ähm,
Damit äh irgendwie in die Gänge zu bekommen. Ja, auch ohne also quasi das Ziel von Akta trotzdem durchzusetzen, wenn auch nicht irgendwie über diesen klassischen Weg. Dieser dieser Schritt von Kanada wird jetzt ähm als ähm.
Also wird jetzt von den äh von den Experten insgesamt diesen Michael Geist äh so gewertet, dass sie quasi dadurch die Ratifizierung von Acta vorbereiten, dass sie im eigenen Land irgendwie diese diese Regeln sowieso schon mal umsetzen,
ähm.
Leider schreibt der Michael Geist immer sehr, sehr lange Artikel, äh in denen er sehr äh lange Absätze hat. Aber äh das ist so die Essenz, die ich dem ähm entnehme.
Jetzt gerade in in Kanada passiert. Er ist halt auch Kanadier, insofern schreibt er natürlich viel über Kanada. Ja, also Kanada will jetzt seinen Urheberrecht äh verschärfen und das ziemlich klar im Rahmen dieser ähm,
einer einer actaartigen eines akte artigen Anspruchs.
Ja, Kanada hat sich ja auch schon lange von davon verabschiedet jetzt irgendwie so der der Hort äh besonderer Freiheit zu sein, also es wundert mich irgendwie mittlerweile alles überhaupt nicht mehr.
Ja, also Akta scheint äh dann da in Kanada noch weiter eine Rolle zu spielen und wenn sie irgendwie auf ihrer Agenda stehen haben, dass äh das noch auch weiter irgendwie der Anspruch besteht, diese diese tolle Idee in anderen Ländern zu äh,
Kompostieren, äh exportieren, äh werden wir sehen, ne.
Okay, da ist dann sozusagen der lokale Widerstand gefragt.
Aber ich finde schon, schon scharf, also das müsst ihr einfach so äh das hört man so in letzter oder was heißt in letzter Zeit, oder fast in der Netzpolitik sowieso die ganze Zeit, ne, dass dass die die dass die Dinger dir um die Ohren fliegen und dann machst du einfach ein Jahr später, versuchst du es nochmal.
So lange bis es irgendwie durchgeht.
Ähnliches äh gibt's auch aus den USA zu vermelden. Nicht unbedingt jetzt konkret acta, sondern.
Also in den USA ist jetzt endlich, kann man sagen, sind jetzt endlich die sixtrikes
aktiv, ja? Das war ja dieses äh Meldeverfahren. Ich hatte da vor einigen Sendungen schon mal die äh die sechs Stufen der der Copyright Warnung in den USA vorgestellt, wo es dann mit diesen Lehrvideo und so
weiterging, ne, dass man dann erst wieder Internet bekommen hat, wenn man irgendwie bestätigt hat, dass man das das.
Züchtigungsmaßnahme zur Kenntnis.
Das Urheberrechtslehrvideo äh äh sich angeschaut und verstanden hat, kurz ein paar Fragen zu beantworten. Nein, das.
Bitte bestätigen sie, dass sie alle Peitschenhieber erhalten haben.
Jetzt. Und ähm das ist jetzt äh tatsächlich in USA aktiv. Ähm man wird also sehen,
Äh wie welche Wirkung da jetzt in den nächsten Monaten sich entfaltet. Ähm wie gesagt, das war ja auch eine nicht-gesetzliche, sondern freiwillige Maßnahme der großen, äh oder der sechs großen Provider in den USA,
Und in Frankreich äh veröffentlichte dann die Chefin der Urheberrechtskommission äh der Kontroll Hadopi, Frau Mirei,
die sagte,
Die sagte jetzt so, ach hier übrigens mit dem ähm diese klassischen Tauschbörsen, dieses Tourenting und so, da haben wir jetzt langsam ein Problem, weil die Leute nutzen das immer weniger.
Klar, ist ja auch ein zu erwartender Effekt, wenn ich so eine Hadopi-Behörde äh errichte, wenn ich weiß, äh
da hängen die Provider mit in dem Torent und verpfeifen mich beim Provider und irgendwann kriege ich irgendwelche komischen Briefe oder so. Ähm ist das natürlich ein Effekt, ja? Das also sie beobachtet die Wirksamkeit des, ja
und sagt, ja.
Du das richtig Französisch aussprechen willst, musst du natürlich sagen, Adopi.
Adopi? Adoptiv.
Mhm. Also.
Äh sie sagt also hier Adopi, äh wir wir kriegen immer weniger Beschwerden, ja?
Und sagt äh, ne, statt jetzt aber zu sagen, haha, äh wir wirken, ne? Sagt sie, ja, das liegt daran, dass äh viel mehr Plattformen für Live-Streaming oder direkte Downloads genutzt werden.
Und ähm,
Da kommen sie natürlich mit ihrem Modell der Beobachtungen auf Providerseite in Tor in Netzwerken so ein bisschen an die Grenzen. Und jetzt möchte sie natürlich ihren den
den den Scope ihrer Behörde natürlich auch auf diese Livestreaming und Direkt-Downloads äh äh richten. Und da braucht sie natürlich dann ähm,
die Unterstützung der Provider, nämlich genauso wie bei diesen Sixtrikes in den, in den, in den USA, wo nämlich die Provider kooperieren und sagen,
Ähm.
Ja, wir äh wir wir bekämpfen mit die Urberechtsverletzung. Was sie also möchte, ist so eine regulierte Selbstkontrolle, also da auch wieder, ne? Wir wissen, äh regulierte Selbstkontrolle heißt Überwachung, äh Selbstzensuren, private Rechts äh Durchsetzung
Ja, dass also das, was eine Selbstkontrolle bedeutet gegenüber einem Gesetz. Und sie möchten jetzt zum Beispiel das Suchmaschinen,
Urheberrechtsverletzende Seiten ähm herabstufen. Und wenn die Plattform die Suchmaschinenplattform nicht kooperiert,
hätte sie ganz gerne auch Sanktionsmöglichkeiten bis hin zum Domainen-Entzug,
Also klassische Sache, irgendwie ich also sagen wir mal, ich google,
äh lizenziertes Werk und das Wort Torent, dann finde ich wahrscheinlich bei Google unter den ersten zehn Treffern ein Torent äh Seite, die mir den, die mir den.
Magnetlink oder den Torent dazu bietet, ja, würde ich das jetzt also mit einem Urheberrechtsverletzenden Werk machen, dann würde sie also gerne einen Hebel haben
Google dazu zu zwingen, dieses Suchergebnis zu zensieren
Ja, also oder nicht, nicht zensieren. Äh Herabstufen, so auf Seite dreißig. Ist ja dann keine Zensur. Ich kann mich ja immer noch bis Seite dreißig durchklicken, ne. Machen wir ja regelmäßig beim Googlen.
Ja? Ähm das würde sie ganz gerne machen und würde Google das nicht machen,
könnte man also bis zum Domainen-Entzug gehen. Wobei sie natürlich jetzt weniger von Google spricht als wahrscheinlich von Seiten wie the Pirate Bay.
Aber das ist also das ist.
Warum fällt mir da eigentlich immer immer wieder nur Brasil ein, wenn ich irgendwie solche Leute höre? Also das äh.
Es ist halt auch, also ich meine, das ist halt auch leider nicht mehr wirklich witzig, ne. Ich meine, wenn du wenn du das.
Das ist, ich meine, das ist einfach Zensur
dass ich meine hier ist jetzt der Name, wenn man wirklich äh genau an der richtigen Stelle, das ist einfach staatliche Einflussnahme, eine Veröffentlichung von Dingen und ich meine, diese Nummer, diese Nummer mit äh Domain wegnehmen, das ist ja im Prinzip
auch schon so eine Art äh äh Variante äh digitaler Todesstrafe, ja. Wer auch schon ein paar Mal äh äh diskutiert haben,
weil das ja de facto bedeutet, dein Business wird komplett zerstört. So, ne.
Ja, also das das äh ich meine, bis dahin ist es noch lange hin, das fordert jetzt diese Frau, die ganz offensichtlich in diesem Bereich.
Gut, aber das ist halt die die Gedankenwelt, ne.
Also wo wir, glaube ich, sehr vorsichtig sein müssen in der Zukunft, wenn ich das mal so als äh sind,
tatsächlich diese ähm Selbstverpflichtung. Ja, also wenn ähm wenn die Provider.
Ohne gesetzliche Grundlage sehr stark dazu motiviert sind eben solche Kontrollmaßnahmen durchzuführen,
und ähm da also eine eine Rechtsdurchsetzung im Prinzip auf einer privaten Ebene stattfindet. Ähm
wo du als betroffener Nutzer dann siehe Beispiele in den USA mit den Sixtrix, wo du dann an irgendwie so ein Schiedsgericht gehen musst, ne, um irgendwie
weil es eben gar keine, gar keine tatsächlich gerichtliche Maßnahme ist und vor diesem Schiedsgericht stehen natürlich einfach die des Rechtsstaats nicht zur Verfügung. Du musst erstmal Eintritt bezahlen, um da reinzukommen, ja? Ähm gut, musst du bei einer normalen gerechtlichen Auseinandersetzung auch, aber ähm,
Also diese diese private äh Rechtsdurchsetzung. Das ist, glaube ich, etwas, was äh,
was ganz unabhängig davon, wie bescheuert die Ideen ohnehin sind, nochmal irgendwie ein Faktor dazu bringt, der der echt sehr, sehr gefährlich ist.
Und äh dann natürlich in Kombination damit, dass man irgendwie noch so ein so ein diffusen bösen Hebel hat wie wir neben dir die Domain weg oder so. Ähm motivierst du natürlich dann die Provider ihre Arbeit
möglichst äh so zu machen, dass sie wenig falsch Negative haben,
und äh um um da irgendwie ihr Risiko zu minimieren und dadurch natürlich,
viele falsch positive produzieren und da können natürlich dann so ganze Technologien äh drunter leiden. Also völlig völlig äh,
undurchdacht und wirklich gefährlich gefährliche Gedanken, die da äh immer wieder hochkommen.
Ja, das bringt uns jetzt äh schon fast zum Ende der Sendung. Ich wollte da nochmal ein anderes Thema aufgreifen, was wir hier vor drei Sendungen, für drei Wochen auch schon mal angerissen haben und zwar ähm,
die sich der,
Transparenzmachung von parlamentarischen Vorgängen auf EU-Ebene verschrieben haben. Wir haben da sehr ausführlich mit Marco Maas gesprochen, der das Projekt äh Lobby-Plug koordiniert. Ähm,
Wir erinnern uns, ein System, was ähm versucht, äh die Entstehungsprozesse von Gesetzen, in den Ausschüssen äh dahingehend ähm übersichtlich zu gestalten,
dass man eben die ganzen Dokumente, die dort eingereicht werden, also die ganzen Vorschläge der Lobbyisten, NGOs, wer auch sonst noch da, äh,
sich engagiert, das alles eben auch sichtbar und recherchierbar zu machen auf der Lobby-Plug-Webseite,
Da ist jetzt, sagen wir mal, einerseits äh technisch auch schon eine Menge äh passiert. Das heißt, das System wird ähm weiter äh entwickelt und ähm,
da so einige neue Features, die jetzt auch, ich weiß nicht, ob sie heute schon freigeschaltet äh sind oder jetzt grade während wir sprechen noch freigeschaltet werden sollen.
Aber es gibt da so schöne Visualisierungen, ähm so ähnlich wie man das auch bei den anderen kannte, äh ja, die die sich ja dem,
nachforschen von Doktorarbeiten verschrieben haben, wo du dann so einen Barcode ähnliche Optik äh hattest, wo du sehen konntest, wo äh wurde viel plagiert. So soll jetzt eben auch grafisch hervorgearbeitet äh werden, wo,
besonders viel Aktivität ist, also wo es viele und wo es viele Änderungen gibt, dass man sozusagen schon mit so einem grafischen Überblick schnell sehen kann, was sind denn eigentlich so die die Stellen, um die gekämpft wird?
Was sind eigentlich so die Bereiche in einem Gesetzentwurf, wo tatsächlich Thermik äh entsteht und das wird dann eben auch tatsächlich farblich hervorgehoben. Das heißt, man kann im Prinzip so ein Gesetzesprozess sich visualisieren lassen,
und schnell erkennen, so, ah, alles klar, das scheint hier der umstrittene Teil zu sein. Das ist natürlich auch schon mal ein interessanter Punkt. Ich glaube, das ist auch schon irgendwie äh online, aber ich bin jetzt gerade zu blöd
das zu finden. Ah ja, hier ist es, gucke mal, hier dieser Browser, genau, Brows Punkt Lobby äh Plug Punkt EU und äh.
Das ist dann jetzt hier am Beispiel von der äh EU-Datenschutzrichtlinie, um dies ja jetzt erstmal vor allem geht, auch wenn das Projekt ja weit darüber hinaus äh ausgelegt ist,
Und äh ne, guckt mal hier oben. Ist das nicht hübsch? Siehst also ganz genau, wo irgendwie so ein ich glaube so ein, so, so ein äh,
Gelbanteil und Rot-Anteil oder Blauanteil, die sagen dann immer aus, wie viel oder Änderung es da gegeben hat oder da gegeben hat, genau blau ist, aber,
gelb ist irgendwie,
und so mischt sich dann halt hier die die Farbe entsprechend zusammen, sodass man eben sehen kann, was äh äh Sache ist. Also da geht's äh voran. Nicht zuletzt auch deshalb, weil die, glaube ich, auch von uns schon vorgestellt wurde,
äh die die Crowdfunding-Aktion, die sie da im Sinn hatten, da hatten wir, glaube ich, auch empfohlen, dass da mit äh gesammelt wird. Das ist jetzt, glaube ich, auch schon abgeschlossen,
Und war auch ganz erfolgreich, als es die siebentausendfünfhundert Euro, die da reinkamen, die sind auch tatsächlich erwirtschaftet worden. In dem
Zusammenhang muss man aber auch nochmal ein anderes Projekt erwähnen, was wir auch damals schon erwähnt,
haben, auf dem nämlich ein großer Teil auch von Lobbyplug basiert. Das ist nämlich das schon länger existierende Pahl-Track.
Und äh ist ein etwas generellerer Ansatz, der die ganze Aktivitäten
des EU Parlaments, also alles, was dort eben an an öffentlicher Aktivität oder nicht öffentliche Aktivität bisher vor allem stattfindet, also an parlamentarischer Aktivität, alle Dokumente, die eben veröffentlicht wird
sich schnappt und äh versucht eben zu veröffentlichen und,
da wollte ich nochmal drauf hinweisen, dass da eine Crowdfundingaktion gerade noch läuft. SOB Speak ist es, glaube ich, noch,
ein Tag äh online. Hier ist allerdings das Ziel, noch nicht erreicht worden. Ähm,
das da werden wir auf jeden Fall auch nochmal äh drauf hinweisen,
weil eben so die Plattform ist, die eigentlich vor allem daran arbeitet, die gesamte Aktivität und äh alles, was dort in irgendeiner Form visualisierbar ist, äh nach vorne zu bringen.
Ich rede jetzt gerade ein bisschen blumig, weil ich natürlich mich wirklich nicht so super im Detail damit äh beschäftigt habe, aber wir haben's ja auch letztes Mal schon gehabt.
Ja, zweiundzwanzig Stunden gibt's noch und die hätten gerne zwanzigtausend,
um die Arbeit da äh durchzuführen, haben da bis jetzt gerade mal etwas mehr als ein Fünftel. Da muss also jetzt was passieren.
Genau, wobei das ist eine Indigo-Kampagne, also da geht das Geld ohnehin dahin. Das ist sozusagen das genannte Ziel, aber das ist jetzt eben kein äh Klippensp.
Ah, okay.
Trotz alledem ähm das ist eben äh auf jeden Fall etwas, wo wir nochmal hinweisen sollten.
Linus, das war's dann eigentlich erstmal für diese Woche, oder?
Äh ich denke schon, ja. Ähm war ein bisschen überrascht, dass letzte Woche wurde ganz oft Logbuch Netzpolitik empfohlen.
Weiß ich nicht. Weiß ich nicht.
Die Sendung so toll war.
Macht mal weiter damit. Ja, empfehlt, erfährt mal Lokbuch-Netzpolitik.
Selektive Wahrnehmung.
Keiner an. Nee, nee, es waren echt ganz viele Empfehlungen. Ähm.
Ich interpretiere da jetzt, was ich sage, aber macht mal ruhig weiter. Damit empfehlt mal den Podcast, ja. Können durchaus noch einige äh Hörer gebrauchen.
Ja, genau. Und Unterstützer auf allen äh Ebenen. Und ähm ja,
erwägt ihr auch mal die ein oder andere für das Programm, würde auch helfen, aber bei so viel Kraut fand man's hier nicht groß aus dem Fenster lehnen. Wir bleiben euch auf jeden Fall erhalten und äh weiter geht's nächste Woche.
So sieht's aus, auf Wiederhören.
Bis bald, tschüss.